so the big trap is instant pleasure like
it's the choosing growth in the moment
the only way to grow your confidence and
grow your business and grow your income
is to choose growth in the moment to
choose the tough decision versus the
easy decision to think about that my
decision now might be tough but it will
pay me dividends later and people just
don't do that enough should i watch
netflix or should i study my business
plan oh netflix it's easy i'll get to my
business plan later should i eat the
salad or the cheeseburger should i wake
up or hit the alarm should i go out and
party and drink with my friends or
should i
look stay back and read and work on my
sales script and almost everyone who
chooses the easy decision has a really
rough life later
and everyone who chooses the tough
decisions has an easy and amazing life
hey sean cannell here and i'm so excited
that you've joined me for this episode
of the think media podcast we're talking
all about productivity tips to help you
achieve more as a youtube creator with
less stress
and giving you a game plan to finish
this year strong and build massive
momentum going into 2022 and i promise
you if you stick around until the end of
this episode you're gonna have tactical
and actionable steps that you can use to
grow your youtube channel and your
business right now now i have a guest
today my good friend peter voog who is
the author of six months to six figures
which has sold a whopping 500 000 copies
and his newly released book seven rules
to seven figures the entrepreneur's
playbook to freedom family and fortune
he's been recognized by entrepreneur.com
he's the world's leading authority for
millennials and entrepreneurs
he built multiple six figures by i think
age 23 by age 27 he uh became a
millionaire he's been in direct selling
he creates all kinds of different
content he creates different mixtapes
he's got the books he's an in-demand
speaker and so definitely somebody that
not only that besides of the accolades
and the results he's gotten in business
and in personal branding in all these
areas he's also a world-class family man
a couple kids now and so i love peter
for so many different reasons but also
because he's no fluff and so let's get
ready to dive into this episode
where you're going to learn some really
powerful information for making this
literally the best couple weeks of your
life
and today's episode is brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com
that is our free youtube class that
you're not going to want to miss but
i'll tell you a little bit more about
that later in the episode so let's get
into our featured content with peter
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm super fired up for this episode with
peter voog and we're gonna be talking
about man how do you finish the year
strong what are some productivity tips
and what are the two biggest
productivity killers that is destroying
all kinds of entrepreneurs and youtube
creators and this is some real stuff
that's going to help you get more
results over the next few weeks so you
cannot just finish 2021 strong but crush
it with momentum going into 2022 but
peter i'm super fired up for having you
here we're talking about the launch of
your new book seven rules to seven
figures and we'll talk about that a
little bit more later but let's just get
right into it with the first and really
biggest problem that's holding
entrepreneurs back and you call it the
entrepreneur's worst addiction what is
that uh it's information overload thanks
for having me i love you guys your
channel your content i've known you for
years so i appreciate you man side note
um it's master reverse overload is what
needs to happen because i think people
right now are so obsessed with
information there's evolving technology
there's information overload there's so
much content coming online every second
that people are overloaded and
overwhelmed and when you're overwhelmed
as an entrepreneur as a creator you
subconsciously seek distraction you
don't even mean to
so what i see especially with the young
demographic and a lot of up-and-coming
content creators youtube creators
entrepreneurs ceos
is people are so obsessed with consuming
and with learning they forget they have
to execute and that's the biggest
problem is people trick themselves in
thinking they need more information when
they really need to execute the right
information that's relevant to their
business and their goals and i've seen
that happen over that was me back in the
day and
i think about it like this if it's easy
it's not very valuable to your bottom
line until your future so reading a book
is not that difficult like you don't
need a lot of uh there's not a filter
system you could go to the store get a
book you can order on amazon that's
great but executing what's in the book
and seeing results is the hard part and
i see most people just don't want to get
to that hard part so instead of
executing or getting outcome focused
they simply just learn more
and what happens when you learn without
executing is you just you don't know
what action to take you have no clarity
you you have noise in your head and you
get overwhelmed and frustrated so i
finally made a list of like okay i need
to make sure before i take any new
information on did i execute my previous
information is this information i'm
taking on relevant to my six month
vision is it relevant to my end goal is
it taught by someone who is the best at
that subject so i don't waste time and i
think if people took that approach
they'd be in a different situation
because people that are outcome focused
produce results like nobody else and i
think most people are information
focused and they get addicted to
information not results and outcomes and
that's what moves the business forward
is results and outcomes and in the book
you told a story about uh someone that
came up to you and was bragging about
how many books they hundred plus books
expand on that so i was talking to him
and he's like dude i've been reading so
much i've read a hundred books last year
i'm like that's great what do you and he
still had he still had a position that
he didn't like
and uh he wasn't moving forward in his
entrepreneur ventures
and i said oh what what are you doing
there oh i'm still at the place but but
i'm learning a lot i'm like why don't
you instead of reading a hundred books
why don't you just read a couple and
then master those and execute those and
start your own business or write your
own book
and a light bulb just like
popped off in his head
because he never had thought about
executing or producing he was only
thinking about consuming because he
liked to feel like he was getting
smarter which is great
but if you learn a ton without executing
i feel like it just dilutes the progress
so he totally transformed and he now has
a book out which is crazy but he he was
so obsessed with reading books and he
never executed them
man that that is probably the message of
now i can't even think of a bigger
challenge right we're talking about the
two things that'll kill your
productivity the first one is this
information overload and then we'll get
into some productivity tips but she
wrote in the book this is what's
happening every
minute
right now facebook users are sharing 2.5
million pieces of content every minute
twitter users tweet nearly 350 000 times
instagram users post 500 000 new photos
youtube users upload 72 hours of new
video content apple users download 75
000 apps 200 million email messages and
amazon meanwhile has generated over 283
thousand dollars in online sales every
minute so there's this this this deluge
of information and consumption more
books to read more instagram to scroll
on more youtube videos to watch and and
we talk about this a lot are you
creating more than you're consuming and
most aren't and people are over
consuming so if you want to boost your
productivity and really finish the year
strong or even if you're watching this
whenever man if you lower how much
you're consuming and so at another point
in the book you talk about how you've
limited
the books you're reading what you're
listening to what's kind of your yeah
that's crazy so i did an experiment two
years ago where
i only listened to one podcast i had one
mentor i listened to just one person i
respected that was doing what i wanted
to do
i didn't listen to a bunch of other
podcasts i didn't read a bunch of books
i think i read one or two books uh that
year or maybe even one book
and because i was so focused on my
mission and because i was so clear on
exactly what i wanted to accomplish for
the business that was the best year i've
ever had in my life results wise income
wise success wise peace of mind wise
happiness wise and everything
so i consumed the least and i was the
happiest with the most results
so i was like dang i'm on to something
here i only like to put things in the
book or or share things that i've
actually experienced that i've gone
through the trenches with and had a bad
experience or a good experience with and
that was a big game changer what i
focused on more than ever sean was
knowing myself what you don't know about
yourself controls your life so i
realized i was consuming so much because
it made me feel smarter but feeling
smarter and actually being smarter and
creating something is different so that
was a year where i
lowered the time i spent consuming and i
just focused on producing and it was the
best year of my life
yeah that's so powerful and so how can
you lower the amount of information
you're consuming of course i mean keep
listening to the think media podcast
smart because it's tactical yeah i mean
check out peterspot those are the two
podcasts young entrepreneur lifestyle uh
get this book but it's the one i mean
but but in realness
a lot of us probably are ordering too
many books we're not even reading them
all and we're our focus and we're
ultimately also trying to execute on 45
different strategies and listen i've had
people tell me sean big influencers
friends of mine hey when you talk about
the mastery thing you're going to kill
your sales and your book sales and your
friend sales but i value truth and what
actually helped me and what i really
think could help people over sales yeah
so it's like if i say mastery versus
overload if people are like i won't read
your stuff that's fine i want what's
best for you really so when we say this
stuff it's like maybe they won't watch
our stuff as much i don't care as much i
care about them actually growing a real
business that helps their family and
gives them freedom that's powerful and
would you agree that oh i mean we'll get
to this in the tips but you need to
figure out what is the number one thing
you want to move the needle on over the
next six weeks over the next 12 weeks
and the book you read or the podcast you
listen to should move the needle in that
one area why are you studying email
marketing if actually you need to get
your health in order why are you
studying uh youtube if actually you're
not even clear on your business your
brand your positioning and everything
else when actually we'll be here for you
your stuff will be there but what is the
thing that's to move the needle and shut
out all this other information the other
thing peter is like
the anxiety is up depression's up i
think people's attention spans are
shorter this information overwhelms
actually toxic
it gets people to not only get deeper in
anxiety but have them be so confused
with no clarity that there's no
confidence they don't know what actions
to take and then when you when you
escape reality your reality becomes
worse and most people they don't want to
face the reality of their stress or
they're struggling or they have anxiety
so they do something to escape it and
because there's so many options
they're like oh my god there's netflix
there's all these things i can do to
escape my reality and what i realize
that i talk about in the book is
if you don't have clarity and you're
overwhelmed and you escape reality
your problem is going to be there when
you come back yeah and it's going to be
worse yeah so it's like the only way for
someone to to better the reality if
you're in a place and you're like i have
to get to the next level i want to grow
my youtube subscribers i want to
increase my income you have to deal in
reality first only way and people don't
like looking themselves in the mirror
i've done it many times and it hasn't
been fun to kind of call yourself out or
face reality but what other way can you
improve your reality and if you look at
the majority of society they're in the
same spot they were five years ago
sometimes worse but if you ask them if
they're gonna crush it the next five
years they're like of course i will i'll
be way out of this situation fast
forward they're not
because they always are escaping reality
because it makes them feel good in the
moment which is the instant pleasure
trap man and that was just like man it
gets worse before it gets better because
that's just number one thing that's
killing your productivity we're going to
share some tips
how to speed up but the second one is is
the silent killer what is the silent
killer that is killing most people's
dreams their youtube channels their
businesses yeah so there was a study and
i've been obsessed the last couple years
with like
science and studies and and not going as
much off the fluff but really thinking
about what's causing people to be
stressed out and frustrated and broke
and there's a study about
any any family or any kid that grew up
in a family that was in survival mode
the lower income families which i have
such a deep conviction to help them
because i i like helping inner city kids
i work with them in seattle that's how i
built a direct sales business is working
with kids lower income so so i really
feel for what they're going through a
lot of them don't have any guidance
but there was a study where if you grew
up in a family who had no if the parents
were in survival mode they were living
paycheck to paycheck and there was no
sense of like this affects this the kids
have zero sense
of what they do now affects the future
they're only in the moment
so they're so focused on the moment that
they never actually create success in
the future because they don't think that
what you do now affects later so the big
trap is instant pleasure like it's the
choosing growth in the moment the only
way to grow your confidence and grow
your business and grow your income is to
choose growth in the moment to choose
the tough decision versus the easy
decision to think about that my decision
now might be tough but it will pay me
dividends later and people just don't do
that enough should i watch netflix or
should i study my business plan oh
netflix it's easy i'll get to my
business plan later should i eat the
salad or the cheeseburger should i wake
up or hit the alarm should i go out and
party and drink with my friends or
should i
look stay back and read and work on my
sales script and almost everyone who
chooses the easy decision has a really
rough life later
and everyone who chooses the tough
decisions has an easy and amazing life
so i
was choosing the easy decisions when i
was 22 23 and it caused me to go broke
shocker yeah so i'm i'm having fun i'm
partying i'm spending my money i'm not
making much but i'm just like making the
easy decisions i'm going home every
weekend because i don't want to pay for
certain things and i'm homesick when i
leave to start my business i'm broke and
stressed
i start making tough decisions and i
always in the moment i'm like should i
make the tougher easy and if i just kept
making the tougher decision i didn't
feel like doing
and my life started becoming more
enjoyable more fulfilling and had more
results so that's it people just need to
understand that
what you do now affects your future so
if you want to crush it in 2022 you got
to respect the next six weeks yeah you
can't be like most people that party and
go out and say ah it's the fall it's the
winter time i could i could hang out i
could eat unhealthy if you want to be
crushing it in your health next year you
got to take the next six weeks serious
that's the trap is just instant pleasure
and i do that i in one of my in my first
book i talked about the decision train
where
most people do what they feel like and
if you only do what you feel like you're
not doing much because no one really
feels like working out no one feels like
doing all these things that are hard
and i think the five percent sean that
are at the upper echelon of success
right now that are having success in
their business and life and happiness
they're doing what they should not what
they feel so
uh yesterday morning this morning both
mornings i didn't feel like working out
i'm traveling i was in texas all last
week i'm in vegas now i didn't feel like
working out but i already told myself
i'd work out so i did it because i said
i would and the feeling i had when i was
done
doing something i didn't feel like doing
is the most exhilarating feeling ever so
i started how you get over this is you
start getting addicted to doing the
things you didn't feel like doing
getting get addicted to the end result
and the feeling of completing things you
don't like doing that is the best
feeling ever and it builds your
confidence and self-worth like crazy so
if people could just do that it's it's a
game changer i mean literally if you
over the next six weeks didn't give in
to instant gratification but the the
lever is delayed gratification and i've
heard that a lot that actually probably
one of the most powerful skill sets of
anybody that's experiencing success is
delayed gratification and if you want to
start building that momentum now you're
going to kill so many things off your
calendar
and that's going to set you up to apply
some of these tips so if we are
um
not over consuming information and we're
making the hard decisions peter what are
some steps we could take to really
finish 2021 strong and build massive
momentum going into next year i think
first is
understanding that moods and feelings
are are killing a lot of businesses
they're killing a lot of uh results and
success and momentum i think the two
scariest things in life right now
especially going into next year is
momentum or lack of it so like making
the decision first like i need to make a
definite decision i'm going to start
building momentum i'm going to make up
for all the times in my life that i did
cut corners that i didn't get my all
that i focused on instant pleasure so
decision comes first if you don't make a
decision
you're going to be at the whims of your
feelings and i i'm just more than ever
sean because of what's happening i'm
stealing i see feelings
kill everything i i see feelings create
divorces i see feelings create broke
businesses i see feelings like killing a
lot of things so it's like being
principle based not feeling based
behind every feeling usually is is
nothing or a weak emotion behind every
principle is a promise you have
principles you execute principles
there's a promise on the other side of
success and growth and fulfillment so i
think if they were to really crush the
last six weeks
it's first understanding what is your
interruptions that have killed your
momentum in the past think about it
logically in the last year what has
killed your momentum
what things have gotten your way is it
distractions is it friends is it social
media is it consuming
and then creating a plan to interrupt
those interruptions
so when i'm creating content one of the
biggest interruptions i used to have was
the internet
i'm like creating content i gotta check
email gotcha facebook
every time i create content i don't have
internet i go to there's two places in
my town that i go there's no internet so
i i can't physically get on the internet
if i wanted to then after the third or
fourth time trying i'm like peter snap
into it what are you doing you're not
here for the internet so just like
getting rid of your interruptions if you
don't have a plan to interrupt your
interruptions your plans will always be
interrupted first thing second is you
have to have a game plan one of the
things i talk about in the book is is i
give people a personalized game plan
that they can follow there's an
execution
list after every chapter they can
actually follow to make sure they're
executing what they're learning
but first thing is create an ideal
vision so for me if i'm going to have a
six month game or a six week game plan
i'm thinking okay what is the end result
at the end of the year january 1st 2022
what do i want to accomplish how do i
want to feel what do i want done
then you work backwards if you ask a
hundred entrepreneurs sean what is your
ideal outcome by january 1st
99 out of 100 won't be clear i want to
make more money i just want to be happy
oh i want to shed five pounds no you got
to be specific you got to be really
specific with what you want and you want
to base this end result
off of what's possible and off of your
potential not off of your past or off of
limitations a lot of people base their
future off of their past insecurities
can't do that that's tricky so you've
got to almost get rid of the limitations
in a way and just say if if ideal if
there was no limitations what's ideal
for you then you work backwards for me i
write down my top five results i want to
create
so on i create a one page plan where i
just have one page i create my ideal
vision on top let's say it's a six week
plan then i create my values values are
more for the longer term six months a
year
but you could still be reminded of your
values in the six six week vision and
say what's most important for the end of
the year okay i have to get my income up
for my family i need a little bit more
freedom for my family usually it ends up
being freedom and family but if you're
in a business you're young you want to
hustle you want to really create growth
in your business your value should be
results in income first right and maybe
more customers figure out your values
next is results what are the three to
five results you want to create by the
end of the year the most important
results that will move the needle for
your business that will actually build
momentum for 2022 and be relevant to
2022 vision
underneath that this is my the part that
really makes it real and i think gives
you the juice is your reasons i talk
about this in the first book as well as
this one
i write down 15 20 reasons always maybe
30. i realize looking at those
70 aren't real reasons that fire me up
like when i wrote down a tesla it's like
yeah i like tesla's but i'm not gonna
wake up before five in the morning fired
up because i want to drive a tesla they
have to be internal so you have to
really dig deep from your past or think
about why you want to succeed and make
these five results happen so write down
your top five reasons that really give
you the juice because reasons come first
results come second
if you don't have strong enough reasons
you're not going to push past the
challenges and if you're not waking up
right now four or five six in the
morning fired up and excited you don't
have strong enough reasons so if you
don't have strong enough reasons to make
the end of the year amazing you'll go
back into old habits so have strong
reasons once you have the reasons down
then you figure out what's the one area
what's the one area the one domino that
if i master study and read about will
make all of these possible
and then from there i just focus on
mastery versus overload and i pretty
much say no to everything else so when
you look at your values and you look at
your goals and your reasons i say
okay my value is freedom and peace of
mind right now
money is not as important because i have
financial freedom and yes i like money
but family and peace of mind right now
comes first so now everything that comes
across my desk is this going to
contribute to my peace of mind and
freedom or contaminate it oh contaminate
i don't want it
if my value is money first which it was
when i was broke is this going to
contribute to my income and my brand and
my and my results or contaminate if it
contaminates you say no so say no to
everything that doesn't allow you to
reach those top five goals for the end
of the year and then lastly i look at
this list and i make sure i'm fully sold
on it if you're not sold on it if
there's one percent doubt you're out
so i feel like the number one reason
people procrastinate
is they don't actually sell themselves
on what they're doing they're not fully
sold that's why you see people change
businesses they have the grass degree or
mentality they're not sold if it the
divorce rate's almost 60 now and if
you're not fully sold on your
significant other and in
one percent of your mind you're like ah
there could be someone else out there
for me guarantee divorce
if you're smoking and you're not sold on
how bad it is for you never quit once
you sell yourself on how bad it is
you'll quit so i think people just need
to sell themselves on their goals and
sell themselves on what's most important
to them and then when they commit to it
and they give themselves a little bit of
a
reward system hey if i hit these goals
i'm going to treat myself i'm going to
go buy a motorcycle i'm going to spend
a thousand dollars on vacation and if it
involves other people it's usually
deeper i'm gonna treat my wife to a spa
or i'm gonna take her here because we
haven't been here for a long time so if
you have a reward system on top of that
that's that's when it really gets
easy to execute because you have so many
reasons so that's one thing i'd say is
just have a game plan yeah sheesh i mean
that that that is getting me fired up
that is the game plan i mean if you
think and you apply this over the next
six weeks i want to encourage you to
actually re-listen to what peter just
broke down because i was like a fire
hose pull out a piece of paper pull out
your note-taking app let the audio
podcast play in the background or or
watch this later save this video
and really map this out because if you
map this out man what are my values what
is my ideal vision
and what are my the results i want to
have happen what are my reasons for
those results you could get crazy
momentum and
i want to highlight what you said if you
say youtube is is the needle i want to
move i want to get growth on youtube i
want to commit to posting this many
videos i want to hit this subscriber
goal i'd like to get these kind of views
maybe i want to collaborate with some
people i'd like to get one or two or
three four people on my channel some
interviews landed like set some targets
like that and then if something hits
your desk which it will
new viral tick-tock trick that's not
growing your youtube channel if
something hits your desk and maybe
health's not the focus new workout
you're up watching infomercials get this
ab roller dude that's not your focus
right now and whatever it is and and
really i believe that think media
podcast community we can finish this
year so freaking strong but also build
massive momentum going into 2022. peter
would you agree with this people you've
helped before that that they're so much
more capable
than they even maybe imagine of what
could happen in six weeks thousand
percent that that some of us
underestimate we've never actually
stepped into what
six weeks
really difficult but what six weeks of
actually turning down instant
gratification could feel like
how what and i like what you said too
how do i want to feel
on january 1st
hopefully not hungover how do i want to
feel on january 1st 2022 i want to feel
like i crushed that whole plan you
either i tell i used to tell my sales
team we always had our company sales
would go like this in december and ours
would always be number one in the entire
company because i flipped the script i
said there's two types of feelings you
can have as a human being in the
holidays in december january one is
proud and accomplished and one is with
regret and frustration sure and what you
do right now for the next six weeks will
determine what feeling you have it's
time frustration and regret or proud and
confidence man there's it's this is such
a real mindset we drift in the mindset
of oh i'm gonna give in to what
everybody's doing i'll probably you know
five ten fifteen pounds i'm gonna gain
so many different parties i'm eating so
many cookies
and and whatever you do you but how's
that gonna feel yeah you're then you're
then gonna be like oh it's january
that's why i gotta get back in the gym
oh i kind of just neglected my youtube
channel like you could treat this whole
season different and you'd end with a
whole different result and peter i like
how you live your life because you you
live it on the opposite of what most
people do it's freeing to you could take
a vacation orthodox you could you could
take a vacation at the end of january
and you could be proud of the results
you've gotten in terms of videos money
income momentum all these different
areas by just making different decisions
right now 100 and i think a lot of
people don't realize 2022 starts for
like the really successful people
if you want to be successful you have to
think and act to like people that are
already at your level i think every
successful person i know understands
that 2022 starts in november december
yeah so if you're like oh 2022 starts
january 1st you're already lost it's too
late already lost and then one last
thing i'll say too that i've never
shared
before in my life i share
some of the book in more depth and they
can have an action list to go with it
the the difference between if you really
you're not executing discipline you need
help you wake up maybe you have anxiety
you're frustrated and you really just
need help with your willpower there's
three different ways to get that help
and the hardest one is discipline people
are are killing themselves because they
don't have this one to do something in
the moment that's hard
the next thing past discipline that's
even easier but not the end-all be-all
is willpower i used to place my toughest
task when i had the most willpower you
only have a certain amount of willpower
in the day and if you waste it in the
morning you won't have any at night
you'll make the bad decisions it's easy
to make cowardly decisions if you're
tired you're you're not a coward but
you're making coward decisions because
you have no willpower
the third thing is lifestyle shift this
is what changed my life i'm not that
disciplined people are like wait what i
just have lifestyle shifts for example
here's a simple example
me and my wife wanted to be healthier
because we were eating sugar we had
sweet tooth at night and and it was just
like we always we would be like in the
morning we're not eating unhealthy
tonight we should have a glass of wine
and i'd have a little bourbon or i have
something ah we're hungry we'd go in the
fridge and get some ice cream or get
some some snacks
we don't have any sweets in our house we
don't buy sweets there's no sweets in
our house so we could have the worst
discipline we've ever had in our life
still we wouldn't eat unhealthy but you
set up a system because there's no food
to beat the ditch it's just none so
willpower with my book when i was
writing this book it was hard to not be
distracted because it was hard it made
my brain hurt yeah i couldn't get
distracted because i had no distractions
i didn't have my phone on me i couldn't
even check my phone because i didn't
have it on me and i didn't have internet
so i had to write yeah so if you if you
give me discipline it'd be hard because
i'd be distracted so if people can make
some lifestyle shifts and just kind of
get things out of sight out of mind it's
way easier if you don't eat healthy stop
buying healthy food unhealthy food yeah
just don't even have it in there another
another example is working out i don't
like working out i i don't feel like
most people are like i can't wait to
work out yeah so some of those maybe
some days okay my my guy horace does
like do that yeah he loves to jam you
know
guys
yeah so the reality is for me we have a
trainer that comes four days a week now
yeah so
probably three out of the four me and
kayla are like
robert's coming dang it but don't matter
yeah the second i get cause he's coming
he's coming and the second i get in with
him it's like sure i'm working out and
afterwards i'm like i feel amazing yeah
so it's like if i left it to the gym
going to the gym fight this week it'd be
harder yeah so it's just my lifestyle
supports my goals
man
are you ready to finish the year strong
hey peter tell us a little bit about
seven rolls to seven figures of course
in the show notes i highly recommend the
book again if you want to focus on
mastery versus overload you can see how
marked up if you're watching the video
version of this podcast uh the the cool
thing about the book two
is i was able to crush it in probably
about five hours in about two two hour
settings on a plane and so it's not
there's no fluff um actionable tactics
that will really help you move the
needle scale your business um and six
months to six figures incredible book as
well but what's your heart behind this
who uh so i promised myself i wasn't
gonna write another book until i really
could not sleep and i had to get this
message out there so a lot of
observation a lot of due diligence a lot
of research a lot of a lot of trials and
errors of building a seven figure
business in the new economy
and i saw people building businesses
trying to get the seven figures working
80 hours they couldn't do it i saw other
people get the seven figures but they
had no lifestyle and i felt like i kind
of hacked the system where this is a
blueprint to help people build a seven
figure plus business
on their terms where they run their
business they have an inspiring
lifestyle and their business doesn't run
them this is not like what did you do to
do it it's not about what i did it's
about this is a a book that help you
figure out your strengths your unique
abilities help you figure out exactly
what industry to get in that allows you
to flourish and helps you hit your
values gives you the scalability you
want teaches you how to figure that out
and how to make moves to where you're
positioned in your industry where
customers and clients come to you versus
you chasing people so anyone that does
want to build a lifestyle on their terms
anyone that values freedom and and wants
to claim some of their freedom back and
wants to build a business that helps
people that allows them to work in their
strengths and gifts
i don't feel like there's any other
blueprint out there that can help them
in a tactical way like this one so i'm
excited my wife told me after the book
i'm so glad you're done with that now
you can be normal again because i was
like such a different person writing and
i put my heart and soul it took me two
years
so i'm excited that it's finally out i
can't wait for people to read it and
actually and i do read a lot of books so
i can say uh that this book actually is
really remarkable a lot of books are
good but they're only about 25
of the main point and then the rest of
the book is fluff
every page is actionable tactical we
were just talking about how one of my
favorite things is every chapter has an
execution plan you're so obsessed with
implementation and not just information
like i don't want them to go to the next
chapter until they execute
you live by that and so uh this book's
definitely worth your time you could
check out that and all of uh peter's
social media and whatnot to follow him
connect with him in the show notes peter
thank you so much for coming on the
podcast my pleasure man thank you
man i tell you what that episode was
like a fire hose of actionable
information from peter but i want to
encourage you a couple things number one
maybe re-listen to that with a piece of
paper out i know i mentioned that but
like it's time to sit down and make a
game plan we don't want you just an
information overload listening to this
podcast but we really want to help you
create a game plan right now and so take
some time to actually put a plan on
paper and i guarantee you this could be
the best couple weeks of
your life it could give you the momentum
needed to end the year strong but also
really sets you up for massive momentum
going into 2022 secondly
if you would say
that the number one area you want to
move the needle in right now is your
youtube channel the number one area you
want to grow in right now is youtube to
be fair as peter said maybe it's not and
that's cool if you've identified a
different area you need to grow but if
it's youtube then do not miss
the thinkmasterclass.com
this is today's episode is brought to
you by our
signature class it's a free web class
that we just updated where i actually
break down in detail the one strategy
we're using to generate over 50 000
views every day on youtube you can watch
it for free you just go to
thinkmasterclass.com
in an hour you'll be able to take notes
and get my best strategies for growing
your youtube channel right now even if
you're just starting and then at the end
of it we also tell you about how you can
go deeper with us in our program called
video ranking academy but here's the
deal if you just want to check out the
free class
don't miss it
we update it from time to time it's not
always available but right now we have
the replay available and so definitely
check that out and it will be absolutely
worth your time especially if youtube is
the area you want to grow
and build momentum in as we go into
2020. now for the comment of the week
and shout out thank you so much for
reviewing and rating the podcast on
apple
uh this one is from boy is a chicken and
it says how are they so amazing i can't
wait to start off the right way for my
youtube channel thank you knox tucker ps
you guys are the best think media man i
appreciate you uh leaving these great
reviews listen all we ask for is an
honest review if you find that listening
to this podcast gives you tactical
information that you can use then it
would mean the world to us if you just
take a moment
jump on your phone and head over to
apple anywhere in the world and leave a
review write and review the podcast
that'd be a great way uh for you to show
your appreciation if you love this
podcast hey as we land the plane
remember we are action takers i hope
you're glad that we had peter on because
you can see we have similar values it's
not just about more information come on
it's about implementation it's not just
about getting some head knowledge it's
about actual results if you're not
subscribed to the think media podcast
make sure you do so because every week
we are bringing you tactical episodes to
help you not just grow your youtube
channel but to also grow a high profit
high impact online business around your
youtube channel and i'm excited because
in the future peter's coming back for a
couple episodes uh to go even further so
stick around and i cannot wait to see
you in the next episode of the think
media podcast